hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well okay so Paul
Marcus and Socrates they're having this
discussion back and forth Paul Marcus
expressed as a particular conception of
justice of right and wrong when we
talked about justice that's not a term
that you and I use an awful lot we're
more likely to speak about somebody
being right or wrong and not just right
or wrong like in one thing but in their
character who they are so an unjust
person is somebody who typically does
things that are wrong right unfair they
transgress the rights of others but just
person as somebody who generally
respects the rights of others does the
right thing they're really just if they
do the right thing without having to be
asked or watched or told what it is
so Paul Marcus says
justice is doing two things what what
are they has to do with friends and so
yeah yeah so you say how are we to say
alright yeah things to your enemies so
people who are on your good side be good
to them that means you're a good person
and part of being a good person for this
sort of traditional conception cuz I
have actually a name for this if you if
you have a name that you can come up
with
that's kind of you know catch you
haven't looked at a name you in this
theory bless you and if somebody's here
out of me then you should be bad to them
that's what it means to be an enemy
right there they already have want to do
bad things to you so it's not just
perfectly okay it's actually a good
thing for you to do bad things to them I
think a lot of people in our society a
lot of people in every society have had
this point of view it doesn't
necessarily mean that you let go off you
hunt your enemy down and you know kill
them till they're family
torture them you know burn their their
legacy down or something like that it
just means that you have to protect
yourself enemies there you know some
people want to take advantage of you
some people see things very different
from from you and are willing to you
know denigrate you or let you a lot of
opportunities so you know think about
how this might work out in a corporate
workplace site obviously unless you're
you know this guy in American Psycho
you're not going to actually find your
competitors and kill them and hide the
body but what would you do in a
workplace to to an enemy cut them out of
a deal what else yeah
scheme them yeah that's kind of an
expert scheme what would you do what
would that be like okay like you set
them up so that there could make a
presentation and that nothing works in
their presentation or their facts are
wrong and they look like a you know they
look like a fool in front of the boss
okay that would be doing harm to your
out of me
what's up what does make those quit
drugs and okay rephrase them for Chris
something that would that would
certainly be doing harm to them and you
know why would you do that to them
because you could presume that they're
going to do the same thing to you if
they can't so this this represents a
world in which we you know everybody's
divided up basically into friends and
enemies friends you know you ought to be
good to them you ought to take care of
them otherwise you're probably to turn
them into enemies you're probably not
going to turn enemies into friends by
being nice to them so you may as well
just treat them accordingly now Socrates
points out three problems with this
point of view and two of the problems I
don't think are actually particularly
good arguments one of the problems of
the points that has to do with this
skills ideas are the other one that he
puts that even he brings up he has to do
with
yes and then the third one the one that
I think is the most interesting is this
is the sorts of question actually so
still it the first to Socrates makes an
argument here that that when you're
following along
it catches polar markets off and you
might actually say yeah this makes sense
but if you look at it carefully Plato
doesn't want you to look at it carefully
doesn't imagine that you're necessarily
going to do that the first second third
time around but if you did you work at
it long enough you'd say oh there's
something not quite right about this
argument Plato quite often will have
Socrates make bad arguments that
actually it tears somebody else's
arguments down and that other person
doesn't catch it because they're not
smart enough they don't have enough
practice in thinking these things out so
Socrates you know starts out by saying
you know things along these lines if
what is it that you're actually doing
when you're when you're being jumped so
you're helping your friends you're
hurting your enemies how are you going
to do that so let's take the business
example for a case is that enough to be
have this disposition to be just in the
sense of having the intention of hurting
your enemies to actually hurt them or do
you need to actually know something else
who best in the business setting can
hurt their enemies or who best can help
their friends
Socrates uses other examples like mad
and agriculture and things like that but
who best in a business center yeah yeah
I couldn't have to do with authority
let's say you're like you know the
middle position all right very good
whoever actually knows that particular
field in Madison if you if you wanted to
help your friends and hurt your enemies
would you know - there's me I mean I
could like you know give you some
ibuprofen and say here this is good for
curing and headache or you can say yeah
don't cure anything right when I was
teaching in the prison bowls get those
guys had very limited access to
medication and so they would buy sudafed
and take you for everything you know and
of course it doesn't work for everything
right you want to go to who would be the
person who fits most benefit their
friends and harm their enemies doctor
right somebody actually has some medical
knowledge and in that case it's not the
it's not the disposition of justice
itself it's the skill that's helping
them do that now what is the is the
skill of Justice actually good for here
he gets block pull markets to make a
bunch of sort of boneheaded moves he
says when is justice actually useful so
it's not useful for medicine or things
like that
when is it actually useful and he says
is it going to be when you're at war no
because at war it's you know strategy or
things like that that are particularly
useful and he says is it is useful in
peace may be at peace so is the
agriculture though isn't it and that's
useful for getting the harvest toddlers
already additional for shoes so he says
tell me what would you say that justice
is useful within in the time of peace
when you're not actually war or
something and so pull the market says in
associations you know when you're
dealing with other people he says by
dealings you mean associations
partnerships or something else
associations and then he goes so that
you go through this list again well if
it's this kind of an association would
it be this kind of person who'd be
helpful if it's this kind of Association
would it be this kind of person
and so finally he gets bull markets and
say well it has to do with money okay so
now we are onto something right maybe
justice has to do with being good to
your friends with money and being bad to
your enemies of life so he says well
when is this actually going to be an
issue
well when money is to be deposited and
kept safe so when is just as useful when
you're not doing anything like though
the things that it has to do that so
Paul Marcus is like yeah okay this isn't
really making that much sense now that's
not a particularly good argument but the
trips polemarchus off leads us right
into the next one who is the person who
actually let's say that justice really
is about you know guarding things you
know I give you some money I say hold
onto this for me and I'm your friend if
you're my friend you'll actually hold on
to it for me and they'll give it back to
me when I need it who's the best person
at hat guarding things yes well you know
let's let's think about this this this
still holds today if you want it if
you're a security system and you wanted
to figure out how to get around that
security system would you want to bring
it yeah yeah why why would you want to
bring a criminal
exactly they actually have knowledge of
if they're a successful criminal they've
actually got some on-the-job experience
right they actually are the best person
at doing that and you know the Socrates
brings us up with others the doctor is
also the best person for poisoning
people if you wanted to do that so
ironically the the just person would be
the one who could be the most unjust and
probably actually has been the most I've
just if you want to keep things safe put
him in the hands of somebody who had
actually knows how to keep them out of
other people's hands because he's
actually broken in and taken that
himself that seems like a paradox to
that's you know it sounds like we have
no idea what justice is these are kind
of you know tricky arguments they're not
that particularly good the argument that
really has the most weight is this this
question that comes up for anybody who
has this point of view who actually is
your friend who actually is your enemy
and this is where things get a bit more
murky so before we actually look at it
what Socrates says let's think about
whether we in our time ever look at
things that way are there areas where we
where we do in fact saying we have
friends we have enemies we should better
put our friends we should try to hurt
our enemies as much as possible I see
you nodding what do you think within
here
when you get in here at school your
friends your anything you're getting
today actually the stuff I was going to
so that's good yeah
does it take time sometimes to figure
out who actually are why we get there
that you trust you come yeah that's a
big one we're gonna you can come to
school and have some people from your
high school
oh yeah that's the same problem yeah
yeah okay so more queens is an actual
friend because a friend is only trust
you like them wait to somebody sees it I
maybe help them then it's close
yeah that's interesting this this this
view sort of like divides the whole
world up into friends enemies very
quickly kid well to two categories
yes let me change it better than a
change for the worse right
anybody find out things about them than
you realize so Socrates brings up this
this problem can we be mixed up about
who our friends and our enemies actually
this is you know Peter sort of
engineered you're talking it takes time
to get to figure out whether somebody
are you know some people we think are
enemies and it turns out actually no
they're just having a bad day they don't
really hate us then are actually having
a belittle towards us they come back the
next week and apologize okay maybe this
person is actually friendly towards me
they took the time to apologize other
people you know you guys have all heard
the term frenemy what's the frenemy
that's a nice phrase that we use these
days yeah pretend to you yeah they're
really out to get you and they're
friends with you so that they can get
close to you so that they can cut you
down behind your back or you know like
like three years we're talking about the
workplace you know something screw you
over in some way a lot of that said
there so there's this problem of
perception there is the apparent friend
and the real friend
there's the apparent enemy and the real
phony and if you're following this this
theory of justice and you go with the
appearances you'll actually be doing the
wrong thing because you should be
benefiting your friends but if the
person that you think is your friend is
actually an enemy then what you really
should be doing is harming them so
you're doing the wrong thing by
benefiting the person who you're
mistaken about likewise if somebody
really you know somebody is really a
friend from the towards you but you
think that they're an enemy and you harm
them where you attempt to harm them
you'd be committing injustice against
them you'd be doing the wrong thing now
how can we tell the difference between
parents and real friends and enemies
what is it that actually makes a person
a friend in your book if you had if you
had to divide the world up into friends
abilities but I understand there should
be a lot of people right let's say that
I had forced you to the side how would
you decide yeah okay communicating if
you don't want so they care about who
you are well that's a good trait it's a
little boy don't go out of their way to
do something for me about being a yeah
the show good will towards you when we
get to Aristotle on friendship later in
the semester that's we had really
important part of his definition
the friend is somebody who doesn't or at
least you know who tends to do good
the enemy is somebody who does harm or
at least it
but could there be people who are like
potential friends or potential enemies
why is it that the friend knows those
twits it just because you happen to be
friends with them
Socrates goes a little bit further
because poor markets to go to so he's
going to say that your friends that kind
of like what you get it and then once he
got out of you if you guys get something
other you guys tend to be good friends
yeah although I'd like we're gonna stay
with Aristotle you know it really
depends on what you're actually getting
out of the person the lower it is in the
scale of value
it was just usefulness both sort of
friendships don't last very long they
break people get angry one of the things
that Socrates the steering them towards
is that the genuine friend is somebody
who seems and actually is good you want
to be friends with people who are
actually good to treat people like you
said loyally who intended good things
for them who actually care about you as
an individual who you actually benefit
and who are going to benefit from from
you you know some sort of relationship
there are some people that you you look
at him you'd be like yeah I like that
person I don't even know them but I
think I'd like to get to know them
because you're recognizing goodness in
them the potential enemy is someone who
is actually bad now there there's
problems with this right again some
people seem good so that's only an
appearance you get close to them you
find out actually they're bad they
really ought to belong in the class of
enemies other people seem like they're
bad but it turns out to get close to
them they're actual
good this experience with you know
family members who you defend against
other people like yeah if you just got
to know you know you'd realize that he's
not a bad guy now how do you actually
sort of negotiate with this kind of
you're supposed to be doing good to the
friend alright so you're supposed to be
doing good to good people and you're
supposed to be doing that to bad people
there's this fundamental problem of you
know figuring out who these are are we
often mixed up about this or thing is
that actually part of the process of
growth as a person anything and you know
the example of coming to Marisa this
pretty act how many have been screwed
over by entrusting to the wrong person
only half the class I don't even screwed
over in your lifetime not necessarily
gotta Maris about trusting the wrong
person you thought was a friend that
turned out not to be a friend the
daughter brought up something like this
you know she's only ten just just the
other day we were talking about she said
yeah I thought this girl was my friend
and I you know I told her some secrets
and she told everybody the secrets and
they made fun of me
clearly that person was not a friend
person was a friend of me you know the
apparent friend is actually an enemy and
a flirt in polemarchus my daughter now
would be justified in doing anything
possible to hurt that the other kid
right
do you see any problems live it would
come up besides the problem figuring out
who's who that's any other issues that
maybe promise
yeah
so they will they be okay so there could
be a difference between the action and
attention it's like an object of view
but people would take it as a personal
view because I can see somewhere than
enemy yeah but you can actually be a
good person but I can't wait like you
justified reason for not like you yeah
I'm gonna be yeah this is this point of
view is a bit crude but doesn't actually
allow for those sorts of distinctions in
response to your question of is this
sort of just supposed to be subjective
or objective and I said supposed to be
full and that that could be one of the
problems will come back to you so
there's like a polarize you like anyone
that you have any enemy yes they may not
be a bad person
yeah you're still doing harm to them
yeah it's almost like the person is not
a terrible person it just you don't see
them as a friend I think that's a lot of
lines of what you learn here is things
here right so yeah it does it does
polarize things it forces people into
these two camps for years I say doesn't
it dependent on the person himself is
lower than any
somebody else yeah and we have the old
saying you know the enemy of my enemy is
a crab you know a friend of my enemy is
an enemy
yeah not only does it polarize your own
relationships if you imagine is going
through a society if there are already
rivalries for legitimate reasons not to
like people it's going to turn people
into enemies it's going to eliminate the
possibility of Concord these are not the
things that are that Socrates actually
brings up notice the the problem that he
brings up she says when you harm
somebody are you making them better
remaking the worse you're actually
making them worse so you're you're
making your enemy into a worse person by
harming them this theory says that
that's the just thing to do that's the
right thing to do we are actually making
that person in a certain sense less just
more screwed up more angry more or
whatever so the strange thing is by by
doing justice you're actually creating
more injustice and Socrates you know
gives you this this fairly radical my
abuses you shouldn't really harm anybody
even if and that's you know that's
that's that's kind of a tough position
to take where else would be heard that's
where morality yeah well in Catholicism
is a particular institution within the
larger religious body of Christianity
the gospel turn-the-other-cheek
Socrates doesn't go so far as that he
doesn't say forgive me around of me is
right but it is along those kind of
lines and it's pretty paradoxical and if
you if you want to get to the some of
the toughest you know verses in the
gospel that forgive your enemies you
know pray for them
energy that's tough stuff to do because
I mean you save yourself yeah these
people want to hurt me they actually
want to do bad things to me I'm going to
be making myself vulnerable to them so
we're going to actually leave off
they're just noting that